[Music]
thank you
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream q and a segment 159
it's time to uh you know answer
questions it is yep it is once again I
failed to say at the top of the last
hour that Discord sends us the question
they most want answered this week or
that they have voted on wanting answered
this week
um
foreign
and so we're going to start with the
Discord question this week
I have seen experiments where men seem
much less able to handle the equivalent
of Menses cramps or birth contraction
pains that women experience regularly
parentheses NPI
obvious
failed to look what's up
nope not what it means here new product
integration says our our producer yeah I
don't think that's what it means is the
testing somehow flawed or is it that
Evolution has created a pain tolerance
level specific to each sex if the latter
what would the mechanisms be
so I I don't I don't think you can do
this I don't think it I don't like the
equivalent what is the equivalent of
Nancy's crafts or birth contraction
pains like it's men of different bodies
with different different structures
associated with you know it would be
cramping or Contracting and you know
what who who says it's equivalent so I
mean I guess before we even get into
um do men and women experience pain
differently and what might we expect
those different ways to experience pain
B I will say that this sort of Framing
and I'd love I'd be interested to see
what the experiments actually claim to
be doing but every time that I've gone
actually and found such a thing and I
don't know if I found it for exactly
this but it's like oh well we just had
this thing off in its sex space like
we had a man who could never experience
being a woman
um endured the equivalent of womanliness
and look how he behaved can you imagine
like well but but it wasn't equivalent
like you can't do it it doesn't work
that way so that's my what are you
smirking about
that's that's my first reaction I think
I know what's going on here
with a question with me no no with the
question I see no um the researchers who
did this experiment I'm guessing were
only using 10 of their brain
yes yes yes yes yes yes
that is a it's not the same but it's a
similar kind of claim where people will
say it like wow
yeah there's 10 of your brand it's like
just just think for two seconds more
than ten percent it's more than 10
percent which you are doing if you're
thinking
um so like yeah there are there are a
lot of these claims obviously but that
does feel like a differently stupid
claim right right right like this this I
I think the people are trying
again I would be interested I think that
people are trying to do experiments like
this
but the attempt just again over and over
and over again misunderstands complex
systems and like oh it's Steve oh I'm
just going to give you the equivalent of
uh what would feel like to give birth
like are you really because there's a
lot going on there and frankly you don't
have most of the parts with the nerve
endings that feel the pain and like oh
you know the Pain's in your head like
okay that's fine but it's connected to
the other parts that you don't have yeah
yeah I think the problem is
in order we can virtually guarantee
about whatever experiment they claim to
have done is that they had to settle on
some parameter which was equal and let
the others flow
right
number of firings of pain neurons
um but when what happens doesn't matter
but that's but my whole objection here
is like what was the stimulus that they
gave to the men well this is my
objection too is that that does not
amount to the experience of the pain
being related right I mean it's it's
like saying like what you know there
were not a lot of firing Sensory neurons
firing in your hand and then we record
the same number of sensory neurons
firing in your butt and yet you didn't
respond to say it's like well because
your hand is not your butt like they
experience different things another one
of these things that we all knew until
yesterday right right but you know I
think a lot of these experiments are
based on these really fundamental
misunderstandings right right and I
would say uh a place to see this
a place to make your point that I think
it will be easier to understand
there's a question of what molecule has
stimulated your olfactory centers and
then there's a question of what did it
smell like
right those involve a map that we don't
have
right a map in which those those what
the second thing the comparison between
those two things go through what what is
it like what's the molecular formula and
shape and
the point is oh what is that map well
that map is generated by
value yeah oh that smells like lilac and
powder smells like my grandmother's
basement right right like oh well it
does but that's because of the memory
associated with your grandmother wore
the thing and the musty basement and
right right well it can be experiential
it could be hardwired but the point is
it's an evolutionary map it's not a
physical map
so what the experience was is about that
object right uh Stone decays in a
non-biological way it breaks down yeah
the smell of decaying Stone it actually
has a smell yeah but it does not land in
the Decay realm yeah because the thing
that is mapped is biological threat yes
okay so here's this is a an ugly
example closer to what the question is
about
a woman
um experiencing
um contractions the pain of contractions
for birth that she's excited about
uh that pain is going to be realized
differently if uh
the child has died inside of her and
she's having to give birth which happens
it's horrifying right and so if those
those two women are going to experience
that pain very very differently what
does it mean to have a man who again
until yesterday would have known with
complete confidence they couldn't
actually be giving birth is now supposed
to be enduring the pain of giving birth
it's like what like it's I mean it's
just this like it's stripped of all the
context right and like you know and you
know and Menses is different so there's
no
I don't I've never heard anyone talk
about like the joy in that
um so you know maybe that's an easier
one to do
right
um another easier one to do is sex
that the
context affects you know it isn't just
about neurons right or it is about
neurons but some of those neurons are
contextual neurons they are not
stimulation neurons well invents a new
neuron class wow
yeah my point is
um
somebody you're passionately in love
with right even if the neurons are
stimulated physically in the same way is
a very different experience than
somebody you don't give a damn about or
you find somewhat repulsive or whatever
the point is the context the brain
context actually overwhelms the physical
context yeah and so anyway the point is
once you know that and your example is a
good one it
tells you you can't run an experiment
like that and extrapolate simply from it
you might be able to compare something
yeah I mean you know this this is gonna
seem like
completely far afield but I feel like
this reminds me
of the cold Plunge
so we've been we've we've been gifted
this cold plunge and and we've been
doing it and it's fantastic and terrible
and totally fantastic mostly
um and one thing that it does
is
I know for sure I've just never been
interested in figuring out how to
develop a tolerance for cold I've just
like not been tolerant of cold now I'm
going into the 40 45 degree water for
three minutes and then
um actually you go in the hot tub for a
little bit and then going back in for a
minute and a half um or two before
um before get on with it with my day
it's fantastic
at first your body's like holy this
is really dangerous you have got to get
out of here right away yeah and you know
and you know you have the physiological
reaction
but you also have the psychological
at first like I don't it's only been a
couple weeks and I don't even have it
now it's like you're gonna die right no
you're not gonna die now if I fall
overboard in iccs
I'm probably going to be overboard for
more than three minutes and so you know
that's the only thing you know and you
know there's there are limits to what um
the body can take but I know for sure
now that I am not going to immediately
have to like oh my God this is the most
terrifying thing that could possibly
happen like okay no there's part of this
that I thought would be intolerable and
I can tolerate that so now I can focus
more effectively on the things that I
need to do which is to get out of this
freezing water right away yeah right and
I think that those two experiences
maybe a little bit like oh it was a pain
of giving birth oh it's like the pain of
giving birth for a person who can never
actually give birth like the pain
outside of context would like
like
it's not even instructive because you're
never going to
never going to end up overboard in the
way you know you're never going to have
any give birth right something happened
yeah it uh it can't be done because
there's a cognitive map that has
something to do with other things and
the you know the cold plunge trains you
that the
experience of hemorrhaging Heat
is not synonymous with I'm in jeopardy
right
and so you become
you become if if other things in your
surrounding are controlled right like if
no I'm just saying that that particular
experience takes it is natural that your
body should respond to intense sudden
immersion in a cold fluid with uh a high
specific heat yeah with uh
get out urgency yeah because the point
is that can kill you very quickly right
right the fact that the thing is only a
foot and a half deep or whatever
um and that you've done it and then
you've emerged and you weren't in it
long enough to be harmed and that that
becomes a you know
just the same way uh you know a a seal
Navy SEAL trains to face terrifying
things and not be terrified well I mean
telling too that cold water is a lot of
is a big part of that training
absolutely absolutely because the body's
response to it is
foreign
the fact of being in an uncontrolled
fashion shedding Heat at that rate is
very dangerous the fact that you are in
a position to titrate the amount of heat
you lose so it is harmless is
novel it's exhilarating it's all of
these things
um
so anyway the point is lots of these
things modify
something that you could measure that
may not be modified like you know uh
intermittent fasting causes you to
experience hunger and just get used to
letting it pass right it's just
and so the point is but but you were
hungry and the answer is well if I
didn't detect that I was hungry because
I'm used to being that hungry was I
hungry right it's a philosophical
question so anyway yes I don't think no
and and the intermittent fasting is
useful it for exactly the same reason
you're like oh
I'm gonna be traveling there's only
going to be garbage on the side of the
road that I don't even regard as food
anyway like oh that's fine I'm just I
just want to eat right I just want to
eat that day that's fine right that's
fine yeah so anyway it's it's the
modification is happening somewhere that
tells you that I mean I'd love to know
what they did but yeah what they did is
they measured the number of firings in
some system and they ignored the things
that the system was connected to that
actually tell you whether or not the
experience was the same yeah it's going
to be another I think we we think a
reductionist approach to understanding a
complex system where the result won't
won't work but given that the scam or
the Discord server
um let us know like I'd like to see the
reference given that it came out of the
Discord server I will also point out the
confound that a man experiencing even if
they did manage to get exactly so I
don't think the people in the Discord
server actually did the research no no
no I believe that but they were curious
about it and if you were to inflict
exactly the experience of menstrual pain
on men those men would have the extra
pain of feeling like wait a second I've
endured all the suffering that goes
along with being a man and I still have
to deal with this
foreign
I think that was a better joke than you
think it was I will run it by you again
okay when you've had time to recover and
we'll see if you like it yeah no I think
I think I just uh just didn't get it you
can't imagine being a guy and feeling
betrayed that you had to endure
menstrual pain
I think because you're not an actual guy
you have the thank you for noticing yes
you um you failed to understand how for
us uh identified at Birth males
um we get up every day recognized at
Birth
assigned no no we get up every day
grateful that we will never have to give
birth not get down to us we do no we
don't but
it doesn't happen
all right that's true it doesn't happen
because there are those among women who
would claim that none of you think about
it enough frankly right we're ungrateful
we don't spend time no it's not a
gratitude
unempathetic no theory of mine
none
all right
sounds like men with regard to child
birthdays all right all right yeah so we
never got to uh you know those are the
bigger question
um from that came out of that
the Discord server this week which is
like are men and women likely to
experience pain differently I mean maybe
it was just it's implied in our answer
which is like yes
yes and I think that pain perception
uh is
not I don't think that we have a bead on
it well enough to be able to say you
know more or less like you know like
across the whole body
there are different
childbirth is a long can be a very long
process right and so there has to be
selection for just
enduring a long excruciating process on
the other hand
if it's if it's too much like what does
it even mean for it to be too much to
handle once you're in the once you're in
it right you're pretty committed at that
point like what are you gonna do right I
mean unless unless you already live past
the age of like scalpels and antiseptics
and antibiotics
uh
you're just gonna do what you're gonna
do yeah but I actually I I doubt that
there was that much range in how long uh
giving giving birth took um
uh I don't see how hard to modernity
matters because I think you know there's
close to zero time and there's some
maximum amount of time and I think that
maximum amount of time that it takes is
much longer in modern times than it was
in pre-industrial times
I don't know if you if you don't
medicalize it
uh if if you you let women move around
and be in positions that it makes sense
to to be in uh I think you know first
birth still um tend to be later than the
pregnant woman wants and although I
guess all births end up ultimately being
later than you want because the end of
pregnancy is really uncomfortable
um but especially first births just can
take a while yeah
yeah okay should we move on yep
we have a lot of questions here this
week okay
before Omicron
covet seemed to follow the pattern of
one week of cold symptoms the appearance
of recovery followed by a second harsher
week of flu-like symptoms
considering what we now know about
covades
and naive T Cell depletion is it
possible that the appearance of recovery
and worst second week of symptoms are
manifestations of a subdued innate
response
I don't know what the all in caps
covades is referring to here I think I
do okay
um I think it's I don't know that it
originates with Malone but he has talked
about uh a kind of AIDs that is
triggered by
um the MRNA so-called vaccines
kind of AIDS well okay an immune
deficiency syndrome okay some something
okay yeah right something that is not
imagined to be deriving from HIV but a
different correct acquired immune
deficiency syndrome okay uh I do think
that there is a possibility of the
attenuation the cycling
there's also the confound of pax lovid
which is known to trigger this very
thing and
um I don't know that we have good
information on you know
people in different categories yeah um
were you were you asked or not I guess
I'd like to start with the uh the
premise of the question yeah though the
premise is before Omicron covet seemed
to follow the pattern of one week of
cold symptoms the appearance of recovery
followed by a second harsher week of
flu-like symptoms
I've never actually heard that before
um although when Zach and I almost
certainly had it in February of 2020 uh
before it was supposed to be here but I
clearly got it in LA in February 2020
and brought it home and two of us got
sick and you and Toby didn't get sick
and it was Dire
um I did experience the like oh this is
bad but like oh I'm getting better and
then I literally collapsed
um so it wasn't a week you know that but
um but I had not actually and I've heard
a couple of other anecdotes like that
but I didn't have the sense that this
was like a a general
experience and I and I don't and Zach
who had exactly the same strain I did
because I gave it to you I'm sorry
um yeah you're you're welcome thank you
for uh rallying and getting through it
you were sicker than we've ever seen you
before since yeah it was terrible
um because you were a couple days behind
me so I was able to begin to try to tend
to you once I got better
um
I don't know this I don't know that
premise is I don't know that the premise
is right although I do know that at
least some people including myself did
seem to have that experience
yeah it's an odd one I'm trying to map
it onto
the oddness of the disease that we have
repeatedly wondered if it might emerge
from the laboratory origin that's
something about the protocols would have
caused that yeah
um
okay but you so oh my God I had this
turned off
and then we had a break and
I guess I'm
seriously passaging the virus through
different
environments before it becomes a human
pathogen
whether or not you could have
effectively
um two sets of syndromes
yeah I mean we've talked of course about
one of the artifacts of a lab
environment being that you don't have to
keep your hosts upright yeah right like
you have to keep yourself upright you
might not have to keep them capable of
finding food by being able to smell yeah
things like that so I don't know I
wonder yeah
um but with regard to manifestations of
the subdued innate response
yeah I I'm it's going to take a little a
little accreditating to yeah figure it
out
and even that might not work right
sometimes it doesn't
next question
I'll come back so this is written as if
it's a second
I'll come I'll come back to digital
advertising regarding today's trash
information landscape
this is in part because big media like
many others online are currently
incentivized by clicks and Impressions
information sources should be
incentivized by providing the public
with useful and unbiased information
primarily because extremism and anger
get views and Views equal money
I have also seen a very disturbing
relationship between Pharma and Tech
regarding content and information bigger
than anyone knows
no questions just a comment yeah um now
he does have another
down below
looks like another comment
add agencies and pharmac control
ad agencies and Pharma control the
narrative in a way that very few people
are even privy to the ones that are
primarily don't care and the ones that
do are afraid to or are often ethically
prohibited from talking
yeah I've increasingly wondered about
um
the effect of ndas on our ability to
understand our own context
yeah you know there's an awful lot of
people constraining other people from
saying stuff and I'm not arguing that it
isn't a necessary mechanism yeah but I
think the
it seems like it ought to be an exotic
mechanism yeah and that you know no I I
agree
um and just speaking very vaguely
um I ended up signing an NDA a couple
years ago now a year and a half ago and
it was
um
restrictive in a way that I didn't
exactly see coming and I went back to
the person who asked me to sign it
and said I really need to talk to so and
so about this and they said oh well are
they on your team
I said I don't do I have a team like I
are you sure so yeah anyone on your team
you can talk to and I thought ah okay
thank you all I need to do is make you
on my team in order to uh to talk to you
about this
um but that felt like yeah this this was
frankly a an actually kind of good faith
environment in which this person was
saying to me like you're allowed to do
this as long as you vetted the person
even though that wasn't kind of written
into the thing but I did start thinking
exactly about like well gosh no one
expects that I've been bound by
something over here yeah and how many
people are bound by how many of these
things well uh imagine the following
question
how much of the phony consensus
mechanism has to do with ndas
yeah right yeah well and that's like
ethically bound right that's what the
that's what the question the comment
said like will not because they're
compromised or ethically bound not to
and you know ethically bound is well I
signed a thing and it's my word right
right it's it's a it's a modern
it's a sort of legal version of Ethics
well yeah
I think ethics as opposed morals is
about rules yeah right yeah
um
but I do wonder you know we've seen so
much funny consensus as the basis for
those who depart from this are uh
terrible people who deserve to be
silenced or whatever right and you know
that consensus is obviously not natural
but equally obviously NDA could be a
component of it yeah no I think so at a
high level so the same person and I
already clicked those I think this may
have actually been written
intermediately but as long as we've just
got three comments from the same person
uh with regard to ad Tech ad agencies
and Pharma to be more specific oh no ad
Tech ad agencies and Pharma not quite
how we think a farmer's relationship
with direct information sources but
every bit is impactful in my opinion
all right
next question
could China's Draconian response be
explained by their first-hand knowledge
of the work at the lab and subsequently
to potential Downstream impacts of the
virus making it quite valid But
ultimately futile
is it possible to ever have dialogue
with those involved directly
yeah it's absolutely possible that they
know something although the futility of
it yeah raises the question of why
if it's not going to work yeah why do it
um it is also possible
that the Draconian well a
it would be really good to know how much
of what we saw was real given how much
of what we initially saw from China was
phony right
um so I assume that what we've seen
recently
was
the real deal
and if it was it's possible that it
wasn't really about anybody being
confused about whether they were going
to control kovid with it but that it was
a
matter of population
control in light of uh
potential unrest in other words the CCP
has its own agenda and using covid
as an excuse for lockdowns and punishing
people and things
might have nothing to do with
controlling the spread of the virus or
it might
yep
we are first-time parents with concerns
about the infant vaccine schedule
Hepatitis B shot right after birth seems
absurd on its face as does Tdap for the
pregnant mother Tdap is uh
I can't remember what else
and pertussis is that right is it
tetanus though
pertussis I think so it's a whooping
cough and diphtheria anyway
Hep B shot right after birth seems
absurd on its face as does TDOT for the
pregnant mother thoughts on the others
namely Tdap at two months we're
concerned about the adjuvants and are
leaning towards going with a delayed
schedule
um
you're right to be concerned about
adjuvants yep and we
long before we were concerned about
adjuvants uh we delayed some of the
schedule for our boys
um I think we delayed everything that
was delayable as long as it could be
delayed with the logic I mean everything
everything is delayable
uh we did not we did not push the things
that um we did not push for delay the
things that we pushed everything it's
been a while everything that had a range
to the end of the range yeah exactly and
um just I mean I would be tempted to go
beyond that if we had it to do over yeah
because I think there are major
unanswered questions and we now know
just how willing to lie the public
health apparatus is and Pharma the
manufacturers of these things so yeah
there's plenty to be worried about there
is also to be worried about the
consequence of people opting out of
vaccination campaigns that are
generating herd immunity and suppressing
pathogens so yes
um you know I think the thing is I know
that we will be accused of anti-vaxiness
for saying hey actually now you have to
worry about things that we wouldn't have
said you had to be worried about three
years ago right but that's not on us
that is on the people who took our trust
and abused it by you know smuggling in
things that aren't vaccines under that
label telling us that they were safe
when they knew that they weren't safe
telling us they were affected when they
weren't effective all of these things
have caused
smart people to wake up to the fact that
what we have been told could mean
anything so and that's just not on us
that is on them if you're if you're
angry about anti-vaxiness you should be
angry at the vaccine manufacturers and
uh their surrogates in government
because they have created an
unresolvable problem where we in the
public don't know what it is that we
face
this is true
um
yeah I was going to say some more things
maybe we'll leave it there
um
leave it there
true conspiracies are unlikely because
orchestration is difficult but complex
large-scale institutional crime doesn't
always need centralized decision making
uncontroversial example is the 2008
subprime mortgage crisis
that's true although but unlikely
doesn't mean don't happen it just means
they're going to be rare yeah true
conspiracies are unlikely
sure but unlikely does not mean
impossible
yes and I I just don't think true
conspiracies are actually rare I think
you are inferring that they are rare
because the larger they are the harder
they are to manage
small conspiracies are very common right
yeah I mean I think I'm reading into the
question here but given that the
Counterpoint is complex large-scale
institutional crime
I think I think this person is talking
about large conspiracies right yep
um on the other hand
well no I think their point is good with
respect to really large stuff which is
that a certain amount of emergence does
a hell of a lot of lifting yeah
um so yeah
are you familiar with Dr Susan Oliver
back to the Science Channel
she shows data that claims to disprove
Dr Campbell's data and his claims about
all cause mortality is it valid I don't
recognize her yeah I haven't seen it
right yeah sorry we don't we have not
seen it um
yeah
tonsils love them or leave them why did
tonsillectomies disappear with no memo
other than cancer can a case be made for
their removal
yeah tonsils is going to be a little bit
like the appendix
yeah but I think but even I'm trying to
remember I I think that they have a it
turns out known function in the
maturation of T cells is it it's it's
immune somehow yeah yes it's uh it turn
it turns out yeah it's not even it's
simpler than the appendix I think yeah
because the story in the appendix now
involves a like yes definitely useful
um and will tend to go bad on you once
you're living in a hyper sort of sterile
modern environment whereas tonsils are
just
useful and then they can get inflamed if
you get um the wrong area but the basic
story is going to be the same modernity
is causing inflammation the uh hey let's
do something people are eager to do
something it's dumb the right thing to
do is to figure out what modern things
are causing the inflammation and well I
don't I I don't know I don't I don't
know that there's more inflammation of
tonsils now than there used to be well
actually that's the piece that it
doesn't if that's but if that's true
then it's like
the appendix and if it's not true then
it's really kind of a different story
not really because no matter what is
true if there's the same amount of
inflammation of tonsils then leaving
them in place makes sense and if there's
more inflammation then figuring out why
there's more inflammation and leaving
them in place by addressing the root
cause still makes sense yes but it's but
you get there a different way
but
uh yeah I didn't I didn't know actually
the people that mostly tonsillectomies
had been stopped they were pretty pretty
happy to do them when when we were kids
if I remember correctly and my mother
will correct me if I'm if I'm wrong I
used to get toss lettuce all the time I
got strep all the time and uh and I
think that she had had her tonsils out
and it seemed like it would not been a
good move and so she blocked them from
taking my tonsils out even though I was
you know I was a good candidate because
I kept on having inflamed tonsils why I
just take them out and she's like no
just leave it I do wonder if this is uh
another
um consequence of the collapse of uh the
skull as a result of the wrong feedback
stress food well that might be the case
because it will be that yeah
are you familiar with Miracle Mineral
supplement
someone I know takes it from various
ailments and believes it to be harmless
while many claim chlorine dioxide to be
toxic thoughts
I don't know I've never heard of it nope
never heard of it
is individualism a feature of modernity
compare adult humans who leave the nest
and strike out on their own versus
lifelong ancient tribal communes what
are the consequences of this
it's an interesting question
um
you know different
cultures different hunter-gatherer
cultures have different roles of
dispersal and phylopatry that is to say
which sex stays in the in the community
in which they were born and which sex
tends to when they when they marry
disperses out and goes to live in the in
the natal community of their new spouse
and in none of those situations is
someone just being like hey I'm just
gonna go out and you know maybe I'll
come back at some point maybe I won't so
that does strike me as quite new
that in general social organisms have
rules about dispersal and phylopatchery
and here we have humans just like
everyone lives all of you and yeah
um and you know there's no there's
there's no rules and there's no
expectations of return I mean
individuals individual families have
expectations of course but at the
societal level it's it's not
it's not understood that there are such
exploitations
yeah I think this is
um highly novel and
quite destructive of normal processes
that we don't even have names for yeah
so if you imagine
let's say that you are in the sex that
stays in your
uh
natal home rather than leaving
well you are likely to have
found a social Niche where you serve a
useful function not well served by
others with whom you grew up and you
know who were in that context so the
point is that whole village
as people filling niches relative to
each other right if you take somebody
who grew up with that same mechanism
they've filled some Niche that existed
in the town where they grew up and then
they moved to some other town is the
nicho does you do the others with whom
you need to interact have the right API
in order to interact with them like it
just
oh no
um it's the right analogy yeah I know it
is it is
um but it I mean it made me think
actually not exactly to this question
but um
boy you would predict different kinds of
functionality both
both thriving and maybe being at risk
in so I I'm more aware of these
different rules of dispersal and
phylopentry and hunter-gatherer
societies but if they exist in
communities that are more uh stable that
you know that have permanent settlements
um you should be able to predict
different kinds of things that get um
that get undermined if all of the women
leave when they marry versus if all of
them and leave when they marry yep so
you know what to what degree you know
how strong is the town if the men have
all known each other their entire lives
and grew up with one another and filled
the niches that needed to be done by men
and the women are coming in and just and
figuring out sort of on the Fly how to
get along with their mothers-in-law and
you know and all the other women who
also don't know one another versus a
town where all the women
know one another and are doing all the
things that women need to be doing and
filling all those ideas and the men are
coming in and having to figure out on
the Fly how to get on with their
father-in-law and all the other men of
the town and you might expect that
patterns of dispersal and phylopetry
change based on what kind of threats a
population faces with totally sets the
costs is uh more tolerable yes
absolutely
I would love to see you two do a series
of intro videos on Standalone topics in
evolutionary biology like what PBS
space-time does for astrophysics do you
know anyone who can make it happen
sounds like fun yeah it sounds like fun
I'm sure we know people who have various
components but as to can make it happen
I don't know yeah
um something something to add to the
hopper I said where what is a hopper
what is a hopper yeah
um well there's Dennis Hopper I'm sure
there are other people who cares about
this though if we just add this to
Dennis Hopper he's gonna be like what is
what is this right
farming oh in the hopper you're right
the hopper is a it's a are you are you
miked
as I said I think it's a farming thing I
don't know if it's hay bales or what but
it's like this it's a Supply right yeah
yeah no it sits above it's gravity fed
in it you get the next one when you open
so it's a spreading seed
I don't know but I know what it's like I
just don't know what that scale it's at
or anything or what it's for but it's
it's definitely it's gravity fed you put
something in there and then I feel like
I should know this yeah you have more of
an excuse you've got no no no farmers in
your immediate I guess you do have a
farmer in your immediate ancestry yes
um
you don't put them in a hopper yeah they
wouldn't they wouldn't put up with it
for one thing
[Laughter]
dispense one at a time that's how you
make sausage
oh that's terrible that's terrible don't
listen to her
um he looks sausage
yeah
um okay Hopper
you strike me as huggers
any cool evolutionary thoughts on hugs
will you hug Sam if you're able to get
something up in person I hope so
yeah
um that was two different questions
well no it was one guy one guy yeah yeah
two different two different thoughts
very different yeah um sure yeah hugging
um
hugging is interesting here's the Here's
the the
thing you're looking for I think is the
interesting thing about a hug is that
it's uh very close but
you know you are not looking into each
other's eyes so if somebody is
duplicitous and they are
um
hugging you disingenuously it may show
on their face but you don't see it right
you know you don't see this I mean
sure I guess yes and I have I ever ever
hugged someone where I thought Like This
Is Not What It Seems yes right
presumably people who hug people
everyone has had that experience
sometimes it is so far from the first
thing that comes to mind when I think
about what hugs are
oh you're not the hugs are
I don't know who's the hugs are but
that's a that's a ceremonial position if
ever I've heard of one
um yeah
no
well do you have so I went down the road
here on hugs and I thought I introduced
something interesting you don't think it
is it I mean I think it is cringy it is
yeah it's an it's interesting it just um
it sends it sends an odd message about
what it would appear
I guess it sends exactly the message
about what how evolutionary biologists
navigate through their world but people
who don't know any evolutionary
biologists and think that we're all a
bunch of weird
they're not creepy no creepy cryptic
racist like you know sexist all this all
this stuff that people ascribe to
evolutionary thinking uh like
oh okay so how you know how how is a hug
good for self for deceit right like that
that's that's the angle right and you're
like okay how was a hug
um I can still do it with like with
information by talking about information
which is still a little bit like
clinical and weird but like
you get so much
um
you know tactile feedback and I just and
it just it like it feels good this is
like this is a human need it's part of
what the
the horror of the lockdowns was for
people living alone just like no human
touch yep right and yes there's a lot of
ways to engage in touch but uh but a hug
is one of the ones that is widely
available to non-intimates right and uh
and even to you know like really it's
the thing that's available at least in
American culture
um for touch uh if you're anything but
sexually interacting with one another
yeah right and so it's just like it's
it's it's a way to say you know I trust
you I'm here you know and it got you
know I got your back like we we have
each other well maybe maybe the the way
to
um
recover my thought
from where I went with it I'm not sure I
don't think it was wrong I just thought
it was a weird place to start yeah
you're right um but maybe the point is
this I think you can actually feel
whether somebody is hugging you
genuinely
um and so the look on their face doesn't
really matter unless somebody else is
looking at it right
yep
um but the point is I mean you could say
the same thing about
um a close dance right but let's
imagine it this way what if the point is
actually a practiced
a practice liar right has the facial
expressions down
and so what I'm actually queuing on is
not that they may reveal themselves to
no effect when you're hugging them but
that
the point is if somebody is misleading
you by what they say yeah and the look
on their face and then they hug you it
may reveal something they may be tensor
then you know if they if they're in the
middle of a con then you may detect it
from that even though you didn't detect
it on their face because they're good at
it yeah so again it's a it's another
it's another source of information yep
yeah but it's also
um
it's also just like
healing and human and it's one of these
things that
you know in our in our lists that we
love to make of the things that you need
how you need sleep and you need water
and you need nutrients and like you know
human touch
is for I would say the vast majority of
people uh a strong
need uh and without it you don't Keel
over right um but you become less and
less attuned to yourself and you become
more and more focused on like I I need
that that's you know that's frankly it's
part of what it's part of what these
guys do it's part of what having mammals
as pets you know
don't recommend having birds as pets I
never have I know enough people
um but the one exception of my student
who had a crow that seemed awesome
um but
um yeah so cool
um but you know if you gotta
if you've got a snake or a lizard or
fish or fishy fish like it's not going
to be the same as much as I love snakes
and
lizards and even some fishy fish yeah um
but having a a mammal as a pet who with
whom you actually share have a
relationship and who enjoys being petted
uh does provide some of some of the
hug value
yes now I will say that I um I do hug
Maddie the dog you too we should just
not get it she does not get it it seems
you pick her up and hug her she's like I
I'm a labrador have you noticed
um yeah no they
it's odd that the dog does not does not
get that because I mean if you hugged a
person the way you hugged Maddie they
also wouldn't look at you that's a fair
point actually yeah now that you said at
an angle like a 45 degree angle of the
legs kind of dangling off the side
it is funny you'll grant me that very
much so she doesn't resent it no one
just doesn't understand she's a labrador
she doesn't resent anything are you
miked
no it doesn't okay
okay
um
what is it 342.
Scott Adams anticipated and front loaded
your explanation of your method slash
training with if you can't say it simply
it's just word salad oh nice Works guys
um yes uh
that's a lot of word salad with a fancy
window dressing I don't know it's
oh no I mean this this is this is part
of the point right like
if you're still looking for some for a
for an epithet you know for for
a phrase that you can then take that to
the bank and just apply it all the time
everywhere like how did you make Dilbert
like how did you have the Insight that
you had and office politics well if you
really think that is that a phrase that
a simple even if even if simply could
mean in your mind a paragraph which I
mean you kind of you kind of did
summarize it in a paragraph but like
it's not like that and frankly
know that you know that at some level so
yes one thing that we did not say in the
uh the main segment on this
is that I'm not sure I understand what
Scott is doing in the aftermath of his
admission right it's he's definitely
doing a lot of something right and that
something given what he's interested in
right given the hypnosis stuff
um right it may be that he has a purpose
that we don't understand and it's
annoying to hear him say lots of things
that sound like simple claims that
aren't true right
um but it may be that he's trying to
accomplish something yeah just like
corralling the the minds of the people
paying attention to him let's put it
this way if he's going to reveal
something after this
uh episode episode of um
tweets that are uh 60 000 maddening yeah
roughly sixty thousand that's maddening
tweets he's gonna reveal something okay
we'll see what he's got if he's not
gonna reveal something and this is
manipulative where he's trying to
Corner people into thinking something
then you know cut it out yeah totally
cut it out not helpful it's not you know
it's multifaceted
are we supposed to guess what it is well
no there's just a lot of I think
micro
Mo slash immuno I think Mo there might
stand for a molecular viral epidemio so
I'm going to say uh microbiology
molecular and Immunology virology
epidemiology I think is how all those
words are supposed to end even math and
biophysics and biochemistry are all
needed to suss out mechanisms and
solutions
yeah
well I mean it it depends on it depends
on the level of the question that you're
trying to address and yeah yeah I'm
tempted to nitpick you know there's a
point at which uh you discover that the
uh the boat is taking on water and what
you basically need is a bucket and
somebody uh who's ready to bail it yeah
you know so it's not like every solution
if the answer is in well it's it's
multifaceted so I mean we're talking
about the the
we're talking about
covid vaccines virus Evolution all of it
right like that that
if somebody is writing telegraphically
about
Solutions within complex systems yeah um
I don't want to swear that every one of
those disciplines is always necessary
but yes you you might want to check with
them all before you
um wrote the prescription yeah and I
mean note that it should you know it's
it shouldn't come as a surprise that two
of
three of the disciplines that you
mentioned here are already
amalgams right we got biophysics
biochemistry and epidemiology which is
sort of it's you know it's the biology
of health and the public nature of
Health it's both individual and
population Level Health come together so
you know you you each of these
themselves already has a history of like
oh in order to answer those sorts of
questions over there we're going to need
to use expertise from from these two
places and instead of that you know
interdisciplinarity was like that you
know the the magic word in the 90s and
Otts when we were in grad school and
then early in our time as professors
um but it's that seemed like it was you
know crossing boundaries and opening up
new ways of thinking to people who had
been relatively narrow and instead what
you get is these new Fields like oh well
I can claim I have expertise in these
two things but actually I'm just now oh
that's not my part of biology that's not
my part of chemistry I'm just doing this
biochem over here so it's it it is
afforded a new way for people to become
narrow Specialists unfortunately yep now
actually hearing you describe that I'm
going to
take back my initial Instinct and
challenge the assertion okay the
assertion again being it's multifaceted
microbiology molecular and Immunology
virology epidemiology even math and
biophysics and biochemistry are all
needed to suss out mechanisms and
solutions
the reason I'm going to push back is
because by naming those disciplines
one is creating the impression that one
needs people trained in each of these
things to do the job
that's true do not believe the fact is
um
there is no lots of people some of our
best people
have trained in something or nothing at
all and then become absolutely top-notch
in something that they did not formally
train in the point is once you know how
to learn
you can train yourself and some of the
people who have trained themselves are
better than those who have been formally
trained and accepted the same wrong
assumptions and all of that stuff so I
guess my point would be it may be that
things that might fall under those
labels are often relevant to Solutions
in highly complex systems like the
pandemic
um but that I would be hesitant to put
those labels on and say if they're not
in the room you can't make Solutions
because that's going to end up being an
excuse for stupid credentialism and it's
going to make things worse not better
I agree with that
um
I don't know and I haven't clicked on
this link do you have thoughts on
faculty pushing back against woke
administration at Minnesota University
do you know this story I don't think I
do I don't either
will take
it's just really hard to get links off
of here
um
oh it's Hamline
oh it's it's the uh
Muhammad painting oh the story which is
from gosh what a couple oh actually this
is written
this week but um
Hamline faculty vote 71-12 to ask
University president to step down over
Muhammad painting fire and controversy I
haven't paid enough attention I don't
know which valence that's going
um
it sounds like how long University's
full-time faculty on Tuesday as
president Miller to resign over her
administration's handling of the Muslim
Students complaint about an Adjunct
professor who showed Ancient Art in
class Independence Prophet Muhammad
um various Hamlet administrators have
said that what took place in an October
art history class was quote undeniably
inconsiderate disrespectful and
islamophobic end quote an act of
intolerance
and Hamline rescinded its offer to have
the adjunct professor Erica Lopez
Predator teach again in the spring
uh but after a wave of criticism from
across the country Miller the president
conceded last week that she mishandled
the episode I still can't tell from that
I don't remember I still can't tell from
that which way it sounds like the
faculty pushed back on the cancellation
of this faculty member for showing a
piece of ancient art that depicted
Mohammed I just can't tell I honestly
can't tell him she was an adjunct yeah I
read it the opposite way but I just
really can't tell so that is high
quality journalism that allows you to
understand so I can't even I can't even
read the rest of it so um I know the
stories is happening it's big and we've
obviously been paying little enough
attention that neither of us remembers
exactly what
uh what happened although maybe actually
the way the question thoughts on faculty
pushing back against woke admin at
Minnesota University well the question
tells us the way it went so you were
right your interpretation right
um
cool surprised except that I've been
right before
yes and it wasn't always just luck
either no really not I didn't even own a
coin you're not even lucky
thank you
I don't know how to take that exactly
um thanks I think
um
I guess the the
cynical part of me will say that this
got enough press and this was so obvious
a stupid thing like this this Adjunct
professor showed a painting right uh and
the Edmund's response was so out of
perspective and you know frankly
Evergreen and other incidents precede
this and uh no no one wants to become
that so
um
on the other hand that was a stride now
closed it I think you won't be able to
open it easily again
um but that was a very strong vote by
The Faculty yeah
um of course once it you start there are
a lot of people who will just vote with
the crowd
that's true and
I mean that that may be
that may be the answer to the Fermi
Paradox right there honestly
like
he just
a strong vote in that direction doesn't
necessarily tell you that it was all
that different you just got to got to
the Tipping Point and once you're at the
Tipping Point so many people followed
because all they were gonna all they
were doing was waiting on that fence
they're gonna wait
and then as soon as it became clear they
go yeah their weather raining yeah
yeah uh apologies on the spam but the
works of Boris and William James Sidis
might be interesting do you know who
that is they are that's what they it
Williams James William James Sidis
um there's a Boris Sidis and a Williams
and a William James Sidis and Williams
this is not William James this is a
different William James
yeah apparently the tragic story of the
smartest person ever lived who is
William James Sidis one of the smartest
person in the world question mark
well but that is consistent with the
other William James potentially I don't
know who William James is click it let's
see if we could find out William James
isn't isn't in the question
it's will and James Sidis I know you're
we're just trying to just the link that
would tell us more about this was two
different people there's William James
Sidis and there's Boris know more about
William James
do I go with NPR learning dashmind.com
or all that's interesting.com so all
that's interesting sounds like they have
the least stupid holy captured
foreign
all that's interesting.com that
reputable news site that says Williams
Jameson has had an off the charts IQ but
he died a penniless office Clerk he
spoke 25 languages on IQ 100 points
higher than Albert Einstein's but as far
as around the world just wanted to live
his life in seclusion
we'll see what I get
um
doesn't say anything about what he was
smart about
um estimated IQ between 250 and 300.
a hundred percent
his parents really liked him
um they spent Untold money on books and
maps to encourages Early Learning true
child prodigy he could speak in multiple
languages by the time he was six English
French German Russian Hebrew Turkish I
mean you remember this is all that's
interesting guys
um when he was 18 months old he was able
to read the New York Times
this is I don't
know
uh so this was accepted to Harvard at
the humble age of nine the school
wouldn't allow him to attend classes
until he was 11 while he was still a
student at Harvard he lectured the
Harvard mathematical Club on the
incredibly complex topic of
four-dimensional bodies a lecture was
nearly incomprehensible for most people
but for those who understood it the
lesson was a revelation so I I yeah
I don't know and he was 12 then yeah
um
he sounds smart
it might be interesting yeah but the
work oh it's just something The Works of
yeah it might be interesting
um
okay
very silly we're almost an hour right uh
you're at exactly an hour
is amyloidosis on your radar it's two
primary causes or misfolded antibody
proteins and lipid carrying proteins can
cause clotting heart nervous tissues
myocarditis bar Ah that's like syndrome
particularly
Etc
feel like I run into it a few times in
the last couple years but I haven't I'm
not dragging it at the moment yep okay
that's the thing yeah there's a little
bit
track
science is to specialize in
science is too specializing and forget
the forest we lost the trees for the
leaves yeah
actually it's not we're not even at the
forest and the trees at this point
that's good that's I like that that's
very good yep
um
which makes those hyper specialized
scientists Leaf miners which is actually
I think a pretty good description Leaf
miners
yeah so Leaf miners for those of you not
familiar with Leaf miners are these uh
little creatures that leave these uh
patterns on leaves as they excavate the
stuff from inside of them
if you imagine the scientists you
imagine that you're looking for the
forest
and you're focusing on the trees and
then you focused in on the leaves and
then you've got all these little workers
doing inconsequential stuff
um
I think it's a good analogy actually oh
that's not right though oh so I thought
I was just going to Google some pictures
half of the pictures I found are clearly
fake so I'm taking that out there's no
good Leaf oh there's there's a good one
there are some but like I don't trust
any of them now because I mean like look
at that that's that's total garbage
maybe I'm not standing by any of this I
don't I don't I don't trust the Google
image search it looks right to me but I
basically yeah it's plugged in nazak but
I mean that was that was insane like
Leaf miners Google Images Oh I actually
know enough biology to know that most of
those pictures aren't real what the hell
so maybe this is if this was the if all
the pictures looked like that I would
have said yes yeah clearly but uh
don't those remind you set my skepticism
to an 11. yeah
yeah that's a lot of skepticism yeah
yeah it's not gonna be enough no I'm
just imagining that those little leaf
miners are like if the if the forest is
what you're looking for those little
leaf liners are like
exactly yeah but you again
oh it's my leaf okay so I got my need my
screen back if I'm going to answer more
questions
well we have let's see uh where was the
where were even the leaf Miner question
I don't even remember
um
serial sequencing versus directed
Evolution are these not just selective
breeding
well the serial passaging is using a
host of a different species to
um effectively a selective breed of
different organism in this case a virus
organism
um by using sequential hosts so that's
that's different than saying oh I want a
cow with you know this percentage of I
don't know you know lean muscle to not
lean muscle yeah it's uh
so I
agree with the theme that you're
presenting the detail isn't right
because effectively uh selective
breeding you're choosing which
individuals reproduce rather than using
an environment to choose which
individuals are best suited to it in
which you never pick anything you just
expose them to the environment and let
the environment pick and I would point
out that there is a
an intermediate case
uh
uh was it Bill Rice
I think it might have been Bill Rice who
bred fruit flies to survive on nothing
but urine or something like this it was
somebody did that experiment and the
point was that's not nobody picked the
individual flies right but it wasn't a
Serial passaging it was using it was
population Dynamics right right because
it's fruit flies so he started I don't
know if this happened or not and this is
news to me but you know presumably if
it's drosophila he started with like 800
flies and you know gave him dishes with
just urine apparently and you know three
of them survived right and yeah so
anyway that um
that is neither fiction or foul it's a
little bit of both yes I guess that's
true
right except the foul are fish and flies
aren't but never mind you've really got
to be in the advanced course of Dark
Horse to see that
I missed it I there's a weird comment
here what did you say yes our fish but
flies aren't no right and yet they fly
as well
as do as some other fish that aren't
some foul
as do most vowel as do some non-fowl
fish that aren't flying fish
[Music]
bats are flying fish bats bats are truly
flying fish unlike flying fish this
reminds me they're not working hard
enough yes flying lemurs which are
called Flying labors because they don't
fly and aren't lemurs exactly right yep
well you're welcome for that little
piece of Education
imagine this is what we want to actually
be talking yeah imagine wow oh boy
um
I don't know what this means this is
what I was reading when you said it the
first time which is why I missed it
neat to have fauchy co-host the podcast
with you today Heather what happened to
Brett
senator
I have no idea what that means
I don't recall imitating facts about you
talking to some sentence
right okay okay yeah right yes yep that
was brief I think I said one word it was
Senator but yeah yeah yeah
okay
Walker actually says in the video that
the purpose was to create the next
vaccine yes but um but the experiment he
describes is doesn't wouldn't do it and
yeah what he describes so the
what he described was an experiment to
produce variants that would allow them
to make a vaccine right which doesn't
make sense right unless unless I mean I
think you're right uh if you if you
vaccinate with the existing vaccine
even monkeys which aren't a terrific
model and then
um and then you see how the virus uh
changes yeah I mean actually though I
don't the monkeys are a bad model if you
wanted to use them to figure out how the
virus is going to explore space and
potentially what variance it's going to
produce that experiment won't do it
vaccinating them with the rnas that we
use on people I don't think the monkey
background is actually bad I think it
will well I think yeah I had this
question in the podcast and I yeah I I
think
if they can be infected with the virus
then given that the given that the
vaccine is entirely basically an mRNA
Factory yep uh then it should work it
should work and I should tell you stop a
a monkey's immune system is
um
capable of
playing the role right if you vaccinate
the monkey's immune system becomes
alarmed in the exact way that the human
immune system will which then exposes
the pathogen to selection that will find
the loopholes in so I actually you know
that experiment is at least on paper
plausible yep
okay
comment
well
end for the week please consider using
parallel economy not PayPal for payment
processing does parallel economy mean
um crypto is that what that means or is
there something called parallel economy
okay okay
um our producer is going to look it up
yep uh but I think we are
out are we out I think we're there I
think we're there yeah
um
cool yeah it says
a sensor resistant ecosystem is their
tagline and it says the new standard in
digital payments so you can sort of I
don't know if it's good but okay it's
supposed to be like PayPal but they
won't okay yeah thank you for the tip
good yeah
um
great uh
yeah I think we're there I think we're
there I think we're there uh again we
have uh private q a at my patreon
tomorrow at 9 00 a.m Pacific
it is going to be off the hook yes it
will yes yes it will yes it will until
we see you next time whenever that is we
go to the ones you love eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
we have to give him a second yeah sure
but you can start already right you
could be good to the ones you love now
because
[Music]
foreign